we appreciate your
making time in the middle of your day
this is
the frankie lectures and the humanities
at the whitney humanities center
at yale the title of the series is the
value of marx's capital
in there somewhere is the idea that the
people who are presenting
will be rethinking the value or
revaluing different parts
of capital volume one
based on their own work based on the
needs of the moment
the series is a companion to an
undergraduate seminar at yale
and also goes along with the work that
i'm doing as a co-editor but really that
the
new the translator of a new english
edition of capital volume one
my colleague paul ryder at osu is doing
to bring out a lot of the values that
got hidden in the
older translation so the new translation
of capital volume one
translated by paul ryder should be out
in a couple of years with princeton
so paul is here and he's going to help
me
discuss
we need to thank a few people first of
all the frankie family
who make these lectures possible
specifically
richard and barbara frankie who endow
these lectures to present
important topics of the humanities to a
wide and general audience
i want to thank alice kaplan the
director of the whitney humanities
center
who's beginning to do amazing things in
her
new position there right andra malan
boles
who allowed this to happen through all
of her work lyanna here's phil
crowen who's the graduate assistant and
audrey leake
the undergraduate assistant running the
tech
what we're going to do is have a
presentation
which will be interactive with our guest
professor lucia paradela from king's
college london
after that students in the seminar will
get a chance to ask questions
first and to make their comments so they
will put their comments and questions in
the chat
and then we'll give them the first first
dibs
after that anyone else who's in the room
wants to ask questions i'll ask you to
hold
your questions until it's q a time
otherwise they get lost in the queue
and i'm not nearly adept enough to keep
that all in order so i'll
signal you you can write down your
questions on a pad or on your
on your screen somehow and then you can
post them and we'll
get to you and hopefully get to everyone
okay so i want to start as i've been
starting these with a quote
from the author and this is it it's
provocative
and i think true quote marx was among
the first european intellectuals who
supported the struggles of the colonized
marxist learning from the south made a
difference in his understanding of
global
development and global history not only
did marx become aware of the strength of
the asian economies
he also denied the inevitability of
colonialism in china
looking at china's living tradition of
peasant revolts he saw the need for a
national revolution that could spark and
link up
with a social revolution in europe and
here's the
the um peak of this thought colonized
peoples thus
appeared as subjects not only of their
own history but also crucially
of world politics this is a line from an
article by professor lucia pradella
who has spent a lot of time
reconstructing marx's views
about what seemed to be
marginal in a european theory
it turns out to be a global theory and a
lot of what has been called marginal
is really central for marx and has force
in its own right
lucia pradella who is with us today is a
senior lecturer in international
political economy at king's college
london she has a phd from the university
of naples and
tagui dies in ontario
she collaborated on the historical
critical edition of marx and engel's
complete works
in german which is a high distinction
and she's written two books on capital
the second book i'll mention the title
globalization and the critique of
political economy
new insights from marx's writings fits
right into
our topic the value of marx's writings
she is discovering new value in the text
all the time
she works on the understanding of
capitalist globalization of colonialism
and anti-colonial resistance in light of
marx's
still unpublished notebooks in that book
professor pradella has published
extensively on
labor migration imperialism and
alternatives to neoliberalism and she's
one of the editors
of the routledge handbook of marxism and
post-marxism
which should be out soon i'm going to
turn it right over to her
for a presentation entitled capital a
book of labor
thank you thank you paul for this
introduction and thanks for inviting me
i'm very happy to be here
and so i try to
present my topic which is i'm going to
share my screen with you now
in a slightly more original way
or maybe to adapt to the new zoom
era so what i'm trying to do today is to
basically discuss different
interpretations of marx's capital
and um trying to
analyze with you the the role of labor
within within capital and i i just
wanted to start
by asking you please to um
if you can i'm going now to
uh post something in in this chat
so if you can click on the link that
will appear on the chat
and if you can tell me uh what
marxist capital is about
uh from from your point of view
let me just send this
so i just give you two minutes if you
could just type
the first two words that come to your
mind when um
we mention marx's capital and and then
these
should appear in in a window
yeah please don't type them in the in
the chat
try to click the link that i've just
sent you
what are the responses oh look at that
okay so this is basically the word cloud
with the words that
you're still uh i think typing in
but i think we can see that
among the most kind of
[Music]
popular words are probably value
exploitation labor capitalism
surplus value accumulation critique
exchange domination
time economy alienation
well i i think this is quite interesting
uh it's a quite a quite interesting
cloud cloud awards
and um let me
just go back to my um
to my presentation
um
yes so
i think that several authors have tried
to discuss
um what the content of marxist capital
or the object of analysis of max's
capital is
and for many scholars and they think
this is also reflected somehow
in in the word cloud that we
kind of produce together there is
uh some attention to labor and so on but
the
main idea is really that capital is a
good
book about capitalism about exploitation
about value and and so on
and a group of scholars like
nancy fraser or titi bhattacharya
have criticized marx's capital and
argued that
capital would be mainly concerned with
the abstract labor
or labor power in the form in which it
is useful
to capital and for these authors
marx laughed such a reproduction out of
the picture
and this narrow focus on exploitation
would basically uh close off
the analysis of spaces of resistance
which is michael libovit's
argument and for nancy fraser
echoed by david harvey
we would need to expand our
understanding of anti-capitalist
struggles
beyond the traditional marxist canon
and so look not just at the struggles
between labor and capital at the point
of production
but also at boundary struggles over
gender domination ecology
imperialism and democracy and
my argument today is that capital is
not really a book about capital but it's
a book against
capital and in the last instance
it's a book that analyzes the antagonism
between two social systems so between
capitalism and communism
and not seeing these from my point of
view results from the same
refined processes that marx is a place
in the
commodity fetishism so
in order to somehow de-fetishize
the reading of capital
uh i will first
start by discussing marxist concepts of
labor and exploitation and
i will argue that these concepts are
crucial to
this inter capital's emancipatory
potential
and read it from the point of view of
the community of free producers that
marx
introduces at the end of this section on
commodity fetishism
i will then explain why from my point of
view
the part on capital reproduction is key
to understanding
the global scope of marx's analysis
including
imperialism and social reproduction
and i will conclude by discussing what
this tells us
about marx's conception of the class
struggle
and such a revolution both in the 19th
century
and today and before i start i need to
make
a premise because many people believe
that marx was analyzing
19th century england in capital volume
1.
but there mike's also says that he is
using
england as a model to analyze the
overall tendencies
of capitalism and i think this is an
important point that we need to
bear in mind which helps also explain
why the more capitalism develops
the more relevant marx's analysis seems
to be
it's because he's looking at overall
tendencies
and not just a specific historical model
okay so it's clear that
marx devoted quite a lot of attention in
capital
to uh labor exploitation but one could
ask what the
this focus on labor exploitation
really closes off spaces of resistance
and i think it's important to bear in
mind that for marx
labor is an organic metabolism
between humankind and nature and from
his point of view
contrary to the classical economist was
derived
from both labor and nature
not from labor alone and by selling
their labor power
workers transfer onto capital their
whole
living power so they put this organic
metabolism
between humankind and nature uh
in the hands of capital and by doing so
really um this create a complete
overthrowing of the relationship between
humankind
and nature and this is why for marx in
proportion
as capital accumulates the situation of
the worker
be his payment high or low must grow
worse yeah so it's both a qualitative
and quantitative process of
impoverishment
so even assuming that workers
are paid what's necessary to cover their
subsistence and reproduction costs the
value of the wage
for marks is always lower than the value
that workers produce
in the production process and from the
moment they
enter the hidden abode of production
capitalists consume their level power
with the exclusive goal
of expanding the surplus labor time
and increasing the extraction of surplus
value
and that's why the development of the
productive forces
aims at creating a uniform and
continuous time of valorization
that renders labor a purely abstract
and mechanical activity so
in volume uh one from my point of view
and i suggested reading the chapters
from cooperation to
a large-scale industry so those chapters
aren't just describing historical stages
in the development of capitalism
but are also highlighting the
fundamental contradictions
of such development and marx shows that
capitalism renders work a source of
mortification
rather than human fulfillment and that
it impoverishes the workers turns them
into a fragment of themselves and
separates manual and intellectual tasks
enslaving science on their capital so
it's really an analysis of the
progressive subordination
of labor or substantion of labor
under capital and this process
um proceeds hand in hand
with the exploitation and squandering of
nature
and this is why from my point of view
marx's theory of exploitation
concerns the totality of capitalist
such relations and has an important
ecological dimension that
resonates today for example in the
studies of scholars like
rob wallis or john balami foster
and other scholars who have shown that
the spread of
pandemics like covet 19 are linked to
industrial agriculture and deforestation
and so from from this point of view
covet 19
would therefore point to the limits of
capitalism
as an ecological and ecological system
as well
okay let me
so um for marx
one of the fundamental goals of the
development of productive forces
is to repress uh workers resistance
that grows along with the
cooperation of workers
and for max cooperation
is not again just a historical phase
but it's the fundamental form of the
capitalist mode of production
and it's con the condition for the
development
of the productive forces so
in his uh point of view cooperation
takes place when numerous
uh workers work together side by side
in accordance with the plan whether in
the same process
or in different but connected
processes so i want to show you
this slide that basically
visualizes somehow part of the supply
chain
of an iphone today yeah so you can see
here
that apple designs the iphone
in california and then it supplies parts
that are produced all over the world and
are then assembled in in china in
shenzhen
uh by foxconn so now i
have another quiz for you another
question and i'm curious to see
what what you think about this let me
just find it so what
i would like to hear from you in this
kind of
silent way is whether you think
that foxconn
so that workers along the
apple supply chain cooperate
or not so this is the link
it's just yes or no
okay there is a kind of people are
a bit split here so please vote
uh use your voice don't miss this
opportunity
i will now
post this and yes they cooperate
with well
so do you see the results
okay according to do you see the slide
with the results
okay so according to a majority
but quite slim majority only yeah to 35
of you uh they do cooperate
well for 27 uh they don't cooperate
and for nine well nine people don't know
really
about it uh they are not sure about it
all right so i will tell you my
interpretation and then
we can discuss whether um
you agree or or not let me just
resume okay
okay so well actually
um in capital uh
max um tells us that
uh workers and if you if we go back to
the previous slides
here sorry um
so he says that workers cooperate uh
when they work together in accordance
with a plan
whether in the same process or in
different but connected processes
so um i from my point of view
this means that workers cooperate even
if
they don't work in the in the same
location
or in a single workplace but even if
they work in different and connected
locations
so for example in the case of apple they
are brought together by capital control
over the labor power but not
not necessarily for um by physical
proximity
and also in some passages in the
grunderitz
marx argues that the means of transport
are part of the direct production
process
yeah so he seems uh to subsume
space under the accumulation process
so from my point of view but um
i'd be happy to to listen to to what you
think
so this means that in this case workers
are indeed uh cooperating even if they
are not working
in in a single factory but they are
spread
all over the world and
there is an important point about
cooperation because
for max by cooperating workers become
members of a collective worker so he
calls this
a gazelle shaftly arbiter and he also
said that workers
trip off the feathers of their
individuality
and develop the capabilities of their
species so
for marx cooperation is really a very
important
aspect of capitalist production
relations
that is also potentially emancipatory
but the problem is that under capitalism
this unprecedented development of human
capabilities empowers capital
that is a force that dominates and
exploits
both the workers and the environment
okay i just want to move now and
maybe this is also linked to the
question of really what is capital
marks looking at in in capital
because uh well i think that in order to
discuss this point uh
which is really about the field of
analysis and
of capital volume one uh the part
seven on the process of accumulation of
capital
is quite important and this part shows
that if we look at the process of
reproduction of capital the apparent
autonomy of capital uh disappears
so if we look at the reproduction of the
process
um capital doesn't exchange
with the the workers a kind of
independent sum
of value but is actually uh
exchanging the very value that workers
create
so capital appears to be entirely
the product of wage labor not
an independent social force so are
it's actually the workers who create
capital
as the force that oppresses and exploits
them
and at the beginning of chapter 24
on the conversion of surplus value into
capital
marx adds this very important from my
point of view
footnote where he argues
well here we take no account of export
trade by means of which a nation can
change
articles of luxury either into means of
production or means of subsistence and
vice versa
in order to examine the object of our
investigation in its integrity
free from all disturbing subsidiary
circumstances
we must treat the whole world as one
nation
and assume that capitalist production is
established everywhere
and has taken possession of every branch
of industry okay so
i have another question for you
so i found this passage particularly
puzzling really because uh
well i i spent a lot of time actually
trying to understand
what does it really mean here right
and so i'm just giving you a few options
a few options
okay so you can find these options if
you click here
so i think what has probably been the
most
um dominant interpretation of these
is that marx is analyzing a national
economy
so he's abstracting from the world
market
and looking at england in isolation from
the rest of the world
and here you have lenin
luxembourg david harvey a lot of people
assuming that that's the case or
he could be analyzing a completely
globalized system
where national and global levels
coincide
so he says uh what does he say
we must treat the whole world as one
nation
or he could just look at the capitalist
capitalist economy in the abstract and
so
at this level of abstraction really the
national and the global levels
don't really matter what do you think
okay so i must say that my position my
interpretation is a minority here
but at least i'm very happy because the
david harvey's interpretation
is losing so only four people believe
that he's analyzing a national economy
which is an
achievement for me after many years of
debates
so okay um we just
assume he's not analyzing a national
economy which is
good news uh but a majority believes
that he's actually looking at the
capitalist economy in the abstract
while the second
most popular answer is that he's looking
at the completely globalized system
okay
well i think this is a plausible
uh it's a plausible interpretation that
um
he's looking at a
capitalist economy in the abstract
although
i i think that um the idea of treating
the whole world
uh as one nation somehow
makes me think uh something different so
that the
national and the global level still
still matters
still matters in in marx's analysis
and also in my my in my from my point of
view
basically posing this coincidence
between the national and the global
level
actually allows you to understand the
process of expansion from the national
to
to the global level and the from this
point of view
uh it's it's quite interesting what
marx argues in in capital volume one in
the same chapter
because he argues that the incorporation
of new lands
for example or the control over a larger
population
or the application of science allows
allow for an expansion of capital's
field of accumulation
independent of its actual levels of
of development and so this uh seems to
say that actually capital isn't bound to
a given
uh territory and the more it grows the
more
it becomes concentrate and becomes
concentrated in fewer hands the more
its field of accumulation expands think
for example
of mergers and acquisitions or the
mobility of
finance capital and contrary to
widespread belief
that marx believed in the equalizing
tendencies of the
of the system the fact that the process
of concentration and centralization of
capital takes place at the global level
has actually a polarizing tendency
because
capital tends to become centralized in
the centers of the world economy
where higher value-added production
activities
are also concentrated and marx
argues in volume 3 that investment in
the colonies or in today's low-wage
countries
is a major factor that helps counteract
the tendency of the rate of profit to
fall
and also another way of
counteracting this tendency is to find
new sources of cheap raw materials
and from my point of view this kind of
analysis
helps explain both contemporary
processes
of extractivism and also
the major shift of production of
industrial production to the global
south that has occurred in the
neoliberal period
well this chart on the um
top left-hand side by john smith
actually shows that from the mid 70s the
industrial workforce in the global south
has
outnumbered that in the north
and according to the world bank's 2019
war development report industrial jobs
are
further falling in high high
income countries which are the
orange line while they're further
increasing
in um in east asia while the total
uh labor force has been increasing
across
across the globe uh over the last uh
really 20 years so
um extractivism um
and this global shift of production to
the global cells
mean an increasing reliance of western
capital
on the super exploitation of workers in
the south which is something that marx
basically discusses especially in his uh
1861 63 manuscript anticipating from my
point of view analysis about the
relationship between
dependency and super exploitation by
scholars
like rumauro marini
okay so i think i need to
move on uh and i want to discuss
another point uh another common view
that is
that for marx the pro the violence of
primitive accumulation or so-called
primitive accumulation
would recede with the maturing of
capitalism which is what
sylvia federici or david harvey argue
but these kind of readings historicized
the chapter on primitive accumulation
and miss its systemic
content and i also miss i'm sure you
already know this passage
but the examples of primitive
accumulation
in in this very famous passage from the
chapter
uh on the genesis of industrial capital
for example the opium wars against china
didn't take place in the pre-industrial
period but they actually took place
between the 1830s and the 1860s
so this was full industrial capitalism
so from my point of view this uh shows
that for marx industrial capitalism
doesn't eliminate
the methods of so-called primitive
accumulation
but subsumes them
[Music]
under its logic and in particular in the
industrial period
the violence of economic compassion
is so powerful that it takes a priority
over direct violence and this is really
because of the perverse tendencies of
the system
which pushes more and more people into
the reserve army of labor
and these kind of processes for marx
were taking place
both in england but also in the colonies
where in his view the profound barbarism
of bourgeois
civilization went naked
so in colonial india for example the
combination of colonial domination
and industrial capitalism ruined what
was previously
the great workshop of the cotton
manufacturing of the world
and as mike david davis showed in
late late victorian holocausts in the
last quarter of the 19th century the
combination of colonialism
and capitalism led to an increase in
rural poverty
exacerbating famines and causing mass
starvation among the population
and so these continuous constant
processes of dispossession for marx
feed the global reserve army of labor
and the traffic in
human flesh that he is in from his point
of view
the capitalist world labor market yeah
so
this this kind of continuous processes
of this possession basically
feed the global reserve army of labor
and the global reserve army of labor
from his point of view
plays a fundamental role in introduction
because it affects labor in multiple
ways
and in particular the expansion of the
reserve army puts pressure
on employed workers allowing capitalists
to push down wages
and also to increase labor exploitation
in a vicious circle of overwork
and unemployment
that takes place really not just at the
national but
also at the global level
okay so just we go back to the
to the question whether marx really
leaves
such a reproduction out of the picture
well from my point of view it's marks
himself in capital volume 1
who criticizes the classical economist
for leaving out such a reproduction
and he describes capital as an animated
monster
which begins to work as if its body were
by love
possessed and he also uses biblical
biblical metaphors like talking about
money that differentiates itself as
original value from itself
as surplus value just as god the father
differentiates himself from himself as
god the son
or the both are of the same age and form
in fact
one single person and i think that this
uh kind of language seems to be an
implicit critique
of the market approach of the classical
economist
who reduce economic relations to market
relations between
private individuals and therefore assume
their existence that take it for granted
and leave such a reproduction out of the
picture
and this um kind of approach
um is fully criticized by marx who
starts from a completely different point
of view
and he argues as we discussed earlier
that by selling their labor power
workers are actually transferring
onto capital their entire productive
power
including the reproductive power and
this kind of transfer becomes
even clearer if we look at the process
of capital reproduction
from a social point of view and in its
continuous
flow because if we do this we see that
throughout their lives
uh workers uh exchange with capital
their entire labor power
so the fact that capital is buying it uh
piece by piece
instead of a mass like uh
like with the slave uh it's actually a
source of precarity
and dependence on the part of the worker
but the result is always a condition of
wage slavery according
according to marx and so um
this shows that substantially there
isn't a substantial difference with
slavery itself
and the antagonism between capital and
wage labor
also includes the sphere of life-making
activities
and social needs and the gender
dimension is of this antagonism between
even clearer formats in the industrial
period when
really he says the labor of women and
children was the
first result of the capitalist
application of machinery
and marx shows how these developed in
complete antagonism with the
family labor and the social needs of
of the workers at the time
[Music]
marx also shows that although capitalism
undermines the economic foundations of
the patriarchal family
it also relies on it to ensure its
privatized reproduction
and these can worsen patriarchal
domination
from some points of view but at the same
time it also empowers
women and children and creates the
conditions for
overcoming the patriarchal division of
labor
as part of the process of overthrowing
capitalism itself
so of course this brings me to the
question i anticipated
of the class struggle uh
according uh to marx and
it is also quite well known that marx
puts forward quite an
optimistic view at the end of capital
volume one
when he argues that with the development
of capitalism there is increasing class
polarization
and so the revolt of the working class
grows and
this growing revolt is growing is due to
the fact
that accumulation is due to increasing
cooperation which is the basis
of it and the cooperation favors
working-class consciousness and
organization
and so this process of cooperation uh
actually creates the conditions for the
expropriation
of the expropriators so
i i don't know how much time i have paul
we don't have a a um
formal requirement really nobody's um
cracking the whip
over us or you but we want to give
people enough time to ask questions so
if you want to take a little more time
that's great if you want to stop and
take some questions and go back to
something that's also
terrific no i think i need around 10
minutes to conclude
yeah maybe i will leave this uh i had um
i had another question for you but
i i was just curious maybe we can
discuss it later
whether this idea of the expropriation
of the expropriators still makes sense
today
with billionaire wealth skyrocketing
especially
in the wake of the pandemic and the rich
not paying taxes
but maybe this is something we will will
discuss later on
so what i want to do now is basically to
engage with this this question right
because mark seems really optimistically
here
he presents this like there is the kind
of natural necessity
and so this is quite a problematic part
i think of value one
and the traditional interpretation of
this passage
is that for marx
[Music]
industrialization leads to the
concentration
of production in big factories the
concentration of workers
in in industrial cities and and so these
um really would translate in their
growing class
consciousness and making basically such
a revolution
in inevitable but
according to the kind of dominant point
of view this kind
of interpretation of view of the dynamic
of working class power
would be obsolete given the shift of
industrial production towards east asia
and declining power of the working class
in the west and so this would be
one of the many marxist predictions that
proved
to be completely obsolete but from my
point of view
marx's argument is a bit uh more complex
uh than these and i'm just
moving to the to the next slide
well the first thing to say about these
is that for marx
the movement for the reduction of the
working day is the premise for
any advancement of the working class and
the demand for
shorter hours is key because it targets
the link between
exploitation and impoverishment that is
at the center of the process of capital
accumulation
and creates the conditions to build
solidarity between employed workers and
the unemployed
native born and immigrant workers and
also between different genders and
generations in particular working time
is key to link struggles around
production and such a reproduction and
is a demand that the labor movement put
forward in different national contexts
and also became part of an international
struggle
for marx support for the most practiced
workers is crucial for the advancement
of the working class
and in particular he makes the example
of english
uh white uh male workers
who on the one side behaved like as
slave dealers
selling their children and wife but also
max notes that it was their struggle
that achieved the shortening of working
hours for
women and children which also ended up
benefiting
male adult workers and the extension
of factory legislation put an end to the
most extreme forms of exploitation
in the domestic industry which were kind
of 19th century swat sweatshops that
relate on the patriarchal family
brutally to exploit women and children
and so the the extension of factory
legislation
enhanced the process of concentration of
production in big factories and
industrial
centers which resulted from an interplay
of technological and political factor
factors
so from this point of view the work the
class struggle is not a secondary factor
in the development of capitalism but
actually shapes capitalist development
itself
and for the same reason we could say
that the process of concentration of
industrial production in big
fat in big factories or industrial
centers
is not definitive and marx was actually
quite aware of this
and in the 1867 address that he wrote on
behalf of the international
uh the general council to its lausanne
congress
he argues that in order to oppose the
workers the employers in england
either bring in workers from abroad or
else transfer manufacturer to countries
where there is a cheap labor force
yeah so
it's not like he wasn't aware of
processes of
production restructuring but by
presupposing capital's field of action
to be
fully globalized from my point of view
capital makes it possible to understand
what
beverly silver called the dialectic
between workers resistance to
exploitation
and capital efforts to overcome that
resistance by constantly revolutionizing
production and social relations
so this constant process of spatial
reorganization
that is a part of this dialectic
is however based on labor cooperation
and so
it connects laborers all over the world
and creates
new sources of structural
power for workers so at the same time
it weakens from some points of view but
also empowers workers in a new way
and an example of these are the
struggles
of immigrant uh labor were
immigrant workers in the logistics
sector
both in the united states but i studied
in particular
italy uh that even if they're often
very precarious and dependent on
their document and so in a kind of
immune
so immigrant status logistic workers
have a huge potential to disrupt supply
chains
uh through strikes and blockades and so
for an italian trade unionist
aldo milani in a warehouse where fresh
food is stored
for our blockade means between 200 and
300
000 euros lost yeah and this kind of
disruptive potential
helps explain why over the last 10 years
the
the movement of logistics workers in
italy has been able to achieve
substantial improvements
in both wages and working conditions
even though
the condition labor conditions are more
generally
in the country have um
have worsened quite quite substantially
and i think that this kind of
contradiction reemerges
now in the wake of global 19
because on the one side the pandemic is
leading to a massive job crisis
with mass unemployment increasing the
competitive pressures on workers
and so in this way the pandemic is
revealing
the ecological and economic dimensions
of
marxist law of impoverishment of the
working class
but at the on the other side the
pandemic has also revealed the essential
importance of jobs
that are undervalued or not valued at
all
like for example agricultural work often
performed by undocumented immigrant
workers
or care works can work by women in
in the family so i have a question here
if you want to to answer so whether from
your point of view
um the pandemic is only weakening labor
or is also creating new sources
of workers power let me
look at the chart here
okay so yeah
so a majority believes that it's
actually doing both
yeah so 37 against
six for weakening labor and five
increasing workers disruptive power
okay which is interesting
okay
okay so
so i think i mean this this my
presentation today really wanted to
highlight the global scope of marx's
understanding of
of the class struggle and i think that
this has really
always characterized marx's conception
of the class struggle
but over time marx became increasingly
aware of the
challenges to international solidarities
uh in the context of imperialist and
racialized violence and it is therefore
no
coincidence or no accident from my point
of view that
volume one doesn't end with the
expectation of the expropriators
but with the chapter on the mullen
theory of colonization
and um so
um i i liked it when uh paul was
was reading some of the passages about
the importance of anti-colonial
struggles
um in march um already in the early 50s
when marx supported the uprisings
in china and india against british
colonialism
and actually believed that they could
either react
on europe and accelerate the tendency
towards crisis and revolution
or they could be the premise for the
capitalist national development of these
countries
and marx also followed enthusiastically
the development of the civil war in the
united states
and as black abolitionists like
frederick douglass
he believed that the outcome of the war
depended
on the mobilization of african-americans
and therefore
it depended on the emancipation of of
the slaves
and this emancipation in his view was
the premise for
any further progress of the labor
movement because
as it's well known uh from his point of
view labor in white skin cannot
emancipate
uh itself when it is branded in a black
skin
and indeed the movement for the eight
hour day
immediately grew uh in the us
after the end of the civil war and then
spread
uh to europe so when marx discusses the
movement for the reduction of the
working day
he's not it doesn't have in mind a pure
class struggle that
uh between bourgeoisie and proletariats
that proceeds in linear way
ways in separate national context but he
has in mind his international movement
against
both exploitation and oppression
at the end of the 60s marx changed his
mind on the relationship between
proletariat
and anti-colonial struggles and so while
initially in the manifesto he proclaimed
that
such a revolution was key to the
liberation of the colonies
ten years after he was discussing with
angus the dangers
that britain's exploitation of the world
would create a bourgeois proletariat
silent or complicit with his domination
and at the end of the 60s he concluded
that
independence of ireland was the premise
for the emancipation of the working
class in
in england so it was really in the
colonies
that there was the key to the class
struggle even in the centers
of the system and support working-class
support
for the independence of ireland was also
the condition for opposing the
anti-irish racism that was
sparked by the ruling classes in in
england
and um and that's interesting because
it's in the same
period that marx also realizes that
uh such a revolution is impossible
without
women and so he's actually paying more
and more attention to the role of women
within the revolution
and helps draft the program of the
workers party in france in
1880 that actually includes demands
for such a responsibility for the care
of
older people and disabled people and so
for a kind of
sharing of the tasks of social
reproduction
and i just um
i just believe that marx's reflections
and study of ireland uh were
also kind of um
he was actually
[Music]
in the light it was in the light of the
experience in the united states and the
outcomes
of the american civil war that marx
decides to take a more explicit stand
on ireland and comes to a clearer and
clearer understanding that
resisting exploitation requires opposing
different forms of
imperial violence and racist oppression
and so i just wanted to conclude with
the
address that the international sent to
the people of the united states an
address that was written with the input
of marx himself that advocated a policy
of radical reconstruction
including full citizenship rights for
for black americans
and uh dubai's actually
underlined that the what is because a
board address
contained also a warning so that uh if
people
of the us didn't immediately declare
blacks free and equal without any
reserve
they would sooner or later face a new
struggle
which will once more drench their
country
in blood yeah so there is this kind of
increasing awareness that
it's impossible to oppose exploitation
without resisting
imperialism and racism which i think
it's still very important today when we
think about
the relevance of max thank you
this is the moment where everyone would
applaud
and i know scholars don't live for the
applause applause but
it really feels good so i want to thank
you imagine a room of 100 people
applauding
for a tremendously hopeful presentation
i want to give my colleague and
collaborator paul ryder
a chance to engage you to ask a question
and i have a question for you too
and perhaps we can ask the students from
the seminar
to put their questions into the chat at
this moment either privately to me or to
everyone
and then we will go to those questions
and unmute you
paul do you want that sure uh first of
all
thank you so much for that that
presentation um i'm
rethinking a lot of passages from
capital
uh as as i asked this question which is
maybe not the best thing to do
um but uh it really is uh literally very
thought-provoking what you said and
certainly for me uh this this uh
a attempt um to
work marx's various statements about
um the the the world outside europe
uh into a kind of coherent framework
um is very exciting and uh
and i am grateful
for for this really uh
stimulating and and well thought out
presentation um but i'm going to ask a
question that
maybe in in view of this in view of your
the breadth of your discussion uh seems
a little
small-hearted so forgive me for that uh
if it seems that way
i was intrigued by your way of of
framing
your uh distance to uh various highly
influential interpretations of marx by
talking about how
uh the mark his his idea of the fetish
is you
see it or his idea of labor as you see
it the exploitation of labor has itself
been fetishized and
um you know the language is very
suggestive there and
uh i was wondering if you could just um
walk me through that
a little bit um since it it was
stated initially and then you were um
proceeded to your
your reading
yes shall we collect thank you
thank you for maybe i'll ask a question
too
okay yeah that's good you want to do two
at once why not
so that's fine okay terrific well
it really opened up a whole new horizon
for me
i do think thinking of the field of
analysis as global
and the field of struggle is global it
fits my understanding of marx
a lot of that doesn't make it into
volume one of capital
explicitly but it's all over his
journalism
his letters his involvements
so that that really makes perfect sense
but in terms of revolutionary
possibilities
and i'm really glad you brought that up
i take your question to be something
like
do the redistribution of relations
relations of production but also of
exploitation so exploitation has moved
around it's not just within the factory
but in all different
places under all different conditions
it's kind of there's a division of
exploitation i would say today
that's different than in marx's time or
different than he recognized
your question is something like does
this redistribution change the analysis
of capital maybe even the categories
and does it also then change the
anti-capitalist possibilities
and your your position is that well marx
was already there
in a lot of ways and we should turn to
those
and exploit them in order to help um
fight the struggle here's here's a
problem i see
um he was thinking of a collective
action
and the cooperation chapter really
makes this clear over and over and over
again
um he was thinking this the
unity of space and time for cooperation
on the labor floor
is really because the power that the
collective
gets is because they are facing one
particular capitalist who then needs
them
as a collective because it's more
efficient
if the people who pull the iron ore out
of the earth
obstruct the making the steel works
that's one thing but it doesn't count as
cooperation
or as collective action let's say the
means of production is not included in
that for marx
so my question is something like
does the image of a chain bring with it
different possibilities a different kind
of struggle
and if so you know how fair is that
if the collective strikes everyone
sits out and what happens happens but if
the logistic workers the immigrant
logistics workers
if we're depending on them alone to
disrupt the supply chain
that seems it seems highly unfair very
dangerous for them
and different than a revolution so maybe
you could respond to that mess that i
just threw in your
in your hands yeah
okay i think i should uh try to respond
thank you to the two falls
okay so the thank you for your for your
stimulating questions so the first
question
is really about uh my critique of
certain
interpretations of marx's uh capital so
the idea
that um the fact so the criticism for
example
that he's just looking at labor power or
exploitation and this would close off
both the analysis
of such a reproduction and the analysis
of
resistance and i think this is a kind of
very
reductionist interpretation of
the antagonism between capital and wage
labor
and i include here others i really
admire like for example maria miss or
claudio from valloff and others
from feminist scholars who also say well
this antagonism between wage labor and
capital doesn't
include is not a gendered antagonism so
we can't understand the question of
gender
in the in the light of marx's analysis
and i think that this underestimates
first
what what this kind of exchange of labor
power for
a wage is about so
that one uh workers are exchanging
their lea their living power so their
their power as
species uh species being i
just left like a passage from from marx
in the economic and philosophical
manuscripts when
he argues that labor is life activity
is pr is the productive life itself
is the life of the species is
life-engendering life
so it's really so by by selling their
labor power it's
this it's this power this this living
power
of of the species that is appropriated
by capital
and that's why the complete relationship
between human
human kind and and nature is overthrown
so is subordinated under the needs of
accumulation
and this also includes the reproduction
of the species
another point is that um for example
uh scholars like um i don't know how
long i should go but
uh scholars like lisa fogle for example
believe that max isn't looking at a
global system in capital volume one but
a national economy
so since you have migration and other
forms of such a reproduction
such a reproduction cannot be included
in in volume one but of course if
we agree that he's looking really at the
national economy
or at a global economy or a globalized
system
or so on then i think the uh
the dimension of this antagonism is
different
and the the second point i think is that
um
i want to highlight in answering this
question is the question of cooperation
which i think
is a very underestimated aspect
of marx's analysis so i think that
even the idea that by focusing on
exploitation
marx would close off spaces of
resistance
underestimates the fact that for max
value production
is based on cooperation and cooperation
empowers the workers
so if we don't understand these i think
we are closing off
of the spaces of resistance uh in our
interpretations of capital
um thanks if i just might jump in for
let me jump in for a second
uh i i suppose um what
what uh interested me about your
uh likening of these misreadings or
you're
framing them as as a kind of like
fetishizing of the
the fetish idea to an extent
is that it raises the question of
what it is about marx's presentation
language framing and so on
that encourages misreadings
um or is that so in other words uh
for for him you know that's uh certainly
true of
of capitalism um the way it works uh is
such that uh
people misunderstand it um
take some things for others um sometimes
it appears to have fantastic forms
because
it in fact appears to have fantastic
forms but this also throws people off
and so um that's when i'm i'm uh i
perhaps should have said that a little
more clearly and
answered and asking the question
initially but um
what is your your sense of that um
is there something about the obviously
people come to marx
with agendas and you know it's all
very freighted um but is is and the
argument is of course
difficult which you could say is
something that you know
lends itself to misunderstanding um but
you find that there's something about
the framing of it the language
and so on that that lands itself to uh
to misreadings the passage
one of the passages that you had us
discuss or think about
and respond to for example you said you
thought about it for a long time and you
see how it could be read
in either ways in in multiple ways do
you think that that's
fairly typical and
and that's to an extent the the source
of this
well the first thing to say is that
marx's focus in
capital volume one is not about such a
reproduction
so i think uh clearly he's
focusing on the production process um
and and so this could give the
impression that he's looking
at these rather than they can trying to
analyze the totality
of of capitalist social relations and i
think that
there has been a tendency also in the
interpretations of
of capital volume one to see it as
restricted to
the level of the factory yeah or the
national economy
and so this this kind of interpretation
may have influenced a certain idea
uh of of its object of analysis
i also think well we can find
um marx's attention to these in
his notebooks for example especially
well already in the early 50s is looking
at
issues of um of the relationship between
the family and
uh the different modes of production
and and then he's going back to these in
the late
uh period of his life with his uh
what so-called technological notebooks
and that were used done by angus when he
uh added the origin of the family
private property in the state
so
well i would say it's a question of
focus it's a question
probably of the language due to the fact
that
that's not the main object of analysis
and also maybe one one thing that it
is true that as i said it's really in
the late
60s and early 70s
in the work of the strikes in france and
the paris commune and
and so on that he starts to stress this
this issue of the kind of centrality of
women in the struggle
well i think there is a language in
capital that somehow
reflects a sort of nostalgia for the
kind of manufacturing male worker and
some form of kind of traditional family
relations
so there is also this aspect that i
think is a factor that changes
uh later on
i don't think i satisfied you but i
don't know i'm just thinking i i don't
mean to look skeptical thank you so much
and
and i'll move on to paul's question
well poll question i think uh uh paul
north uh
question so i think it's a it's a very
important question
because um yes
um okay there are two things
that i want to highlight here one is the
question whether the
the kind of global redistribution of uh
workers today and the kind of
restructuring of production
really um changes uh marx's
analysis and also about the
revolutionary possibilities
well on the one side i would say it
doesn't change it it's actually i
see as i think that he's not looking at
19th century england but as i i believe
he's
posing this uh completely globalized
system
yeah where capitalist production has
established itself
everywhere so i think that
um what we're witnessing today is
actually an approximation to these
limits that
is opposing in capital and so for
example the fact that
production has industrial production has
relocated to the south
and the west like in
europe and the us and japan have lost
their
industrial monopoly has actually
globalized industrial competition
and so this is uh manifesting the
impoverished
impoverishing tendencies of the system
in a much clearer way
so this is actually allowing a
uh the development of these tendencies
uh
to unfold or these tendencies to unfold
but i agree with you that i think that's
actually the key
so and i think there is an ambiguity in
marx himself
about this concept of cooperation
because
on the one side there is this idea that
there is
uh some form of unity of space and time
and so cooperation would emerge from
these
right and so these hubs explain the kind
of very optimistic tone
of the of the end of the
the part of the expropriation of the
expropriators
so the idea that actually so there is
this kind of
cooperation that grounds working class
organization consciousness
and and so on on the other side i think
that
there is still um this form
of unity space and time unity
even if we look at this entire supply
chain
right not just because of the disruption
of logistics but for example beverly
silver
shows that especially given just in time
production
um even if we stop a part of the supply
chain
this can have a disruptive potential all
over the chain
right can i ask a question about that
just while you're on it
just thinking of marx's presentation of
cooperation in volume one
it really is that the collective faces
off against
one capitalist who owns their means of
production
so what's to keep apple from say there's
resistance at some point in the supply
chain
just shifting the supplier that's what
can't happen
let's say in this work space
where the capitalist absolutely needs
everyone to be working together in order
to get their return
and they can't do it otherwise so if the
cooperation breaks down there
it's tantamount to them losing their
business
or not you know becoming impossible for
them to continue as a capitalist
whereas apple can simply change their
suppliers
but i mean isn't it the same thing that
max was describing
in the address to the lausanne congress
so that in order to face uh worker
struggles
english capitalists while moving
production to
countries where wages were lower so
it's it's it's the same
sorry i don't hear you
i just think it's a very specific
argument about
cooperation that leads to an idea of
collective action
and the idea of revolution as a kind of
overthrow
of one capitalist or of the whole system
and
well if the um the relocated
manufacturer let's say
is still directly responsible for the
capitalists
profit that's fine
then it works but insofar as they can
simply switch suppliers
so that's where marx makes the
difference between means of production
and production i don't mean to get very
technical
i only think it's worth sticking with
marx's framework
and developing other vocabulary
and other revolutionary possibilities
that you brought up
but disruption is very different than
overthrow is very different than crisis
it's not actually a term i think that
marx uses disruption blockade
i don't know if that makes sense
um
[Music]
well i think that the i mean the
the power for disruption i mean it's not
a term that he uses but
we can explain the power for disruption
to cope
through cooperation because it's the
fact that
the division of labor is uh so developed
means that it requires increasing
cooperation yeah in order to produce a
product
and this uh creates uh possibilities for
disruption
so i think it's um directly proportional
to
the process of cooperation
okay i think that's a great that's a
great answer
uh maybe it's a good time to turn to a
couple of questions from
students in the seminar and then we can
open up the floor to other people i know
there's a lot of comments and questions
i want to turn to bilal
who's a student in the seminar audrey if
you're
hearing me would you open up his mic
yes can you repeat their name please
m-o-i-n
uh well i had a question about about
cooperation
um so when marx describes the
subjugation of colonies he often you
know brings up the the divisory schisms
in society
that the capitalist creates and takes
advantage of when he oppresses the
masses and this is made quite evident
when he talks about the
indian sepoy mutiny of 1857 and he
specifically references the british
divide at emperor policies
uh so given that a marx describes the
unity of masters
uh and the value of the unity of mass is
to overcome cooperation
or does he see corporation as only a
tool to oppress the workers or could it
also be an agency of freedom
specifically in this context
thank you did we go on to some more
questions you want to collect them
okay great um why don't we go to nancy
so that's
there's only one student who proposed a
question so anyone else from the seminar
who wants to
pop a question in the chat we can come
back to you
but we can go now to nancy co
hi thank you so much um i'm nancy i'm a
phd student at columbia actually
um so i'm curious as to um whether you
can
talk about your interpretation as it
might relate to moisture for stones
um in time labor and social capital the
reason i bring up the stone's
interpretation of marx
is that um i think one thing that's sort
of bothering me in the way that we're
talking about labor here is that we're
only talking about a sort of concrete
aspect so we're talking about for
example
apple's laborers but for pastone
importantly
in capital labor is both concrete a
thing that produces use values
but also socially general and abstract
and produces value as the form of wealth
and capitalism
so i wonder if this might
partially account for the difficulty of
um revolution interpreting that as we
may
precisely that um labor
you know in only its concrete form or
interpreted only in this concrete form
escapes this other aspect of of labor
and then um with regard to
kind of this sort of one of your last
slides about
um what to do with marx's capital
today i think pastone would say that i
mean he recently passed away but i think
he would say that um
marx is more relevant now than
ever not just because capital as you
said
um wasn't just a historical account but
a
a sort of theory of a system but
i i wonder if you could speak
specifically to his idea of sort of
the kind of treadmill effect right um so
the ways in which um due to the kind of
temporally determined nature of value
um value becomes you know
distributed ever more thinly across a
kind of ever-growing sum of
commodities and so on that account of
the treadmill effect
um proletarian labor becomes
increasingly anachronistic
right um and so in contrast material
wealth
right like the super billionaires like
jeff bezos
um their material wealth becomes ever
easy to accommodate
accumulate rather at the same time that
um
the value of proletarian labor becomes
increasingly irrelevant
to their resistance so i wonder because
we're bringing up this whole
troubling thing of the fact that the
very people that we think
marx holds responsible for the
possibility of revolution are also the
most vulnerable
i don't think that he's holding them
responsible for that revolution i don't
think that he sees
or he saw the proletariat class as the
standpoint of the critique i think as
postone says capital
is a critique of labor in capitalism not
a critique of capital from the
standpoint of labor
do you want to go from here or do you
want to take one more
i would take one more yes thank you
thank you nancy
i want to invite berta morata to
ask their question
would you like to go ahead
i can also read out the question for you
if you prefer
they might be they're unmuted i can see
that but they might be having trouble
with
mics or whatever why don't i read the
question it came a little while ago
it says how can the reading of capital
help challenge
the productive forces for example an
extraction of iron ore in kiruna
where workers are highly paid and
extraction outputs or appropriation ever
increasing
it's the biggest iron ore mine in the
world
guess they want to know how capital can
be useful in challenging that
where it's getting bigger and bigger and
the i guess the exploitation is not as
obvious
professor bradella i'll leave this to
you now okay
thank you thank you everyone for
for these questions um yes bilal
um i'm not sure i fully i fully
understood but uh
i definitely agree that um there is this
important emancipatory dimension of
marx's analysis of cooperation
and yes so this also applies of course
uh to the colonies
regarding the question about
labor in capital and um customs
interpretation well i think that what
the the interpretation i put forward is
actually quite
um the opposite to both stones
first because uh as as regard with
regard to
concrete and abstract labor i think that
um i mean from my point of view i'm not
an expert on posttone but
uh it seems to fetishize capital
and basically um
overlook the dialectic between concrete
and abstract labor
and what i wanted to say in particular
was that
the reduction of concrete labor to
abstract labor
is a violent process that takes place in
the production process
right that helps explain also workers
revolt
yeah and opposition to the development
of the productive forces
and the idea that uh marx
that capital is a book um
in which basically capital is a subject
from my point of view completely
overlooks the fact that
in the section in the part on capital
reproduction
marks as that if we look at the
reproduction of the relationship
capital is just objectified that labor
right so from from the point of view of
the totality
it's the working class that reproduces
itself as dependent on capital
and so the power to change things today
is still
the power of the working class from my
point of view and this is because um
they control the production process and
this has become even more clear today
in the wake of the pandemic how
important workers are
how for example there is a mckinsey
report
that shows that because of national
natural disasters
climate change and stuff like that um
corporations are going to stop a month
uh they have a disruption of one month
every seven years
and this will cost them a huge amount of
money i don't remember
how much money but i couldn't believe it
so the idea that
the c both the workers and of course the
natural disasters caused by capitalism
can produce such such a disruption i
think
helps explain uh so because of their
structural power
why the workers today still have uh this
power
and they are showing this maybe it's
more difficult for us
in in europe or in the west but
chinese workers uh indian workers and so
on have been engaged in waves of
labor unrest over the last decades and
this has
led to concrete improvements in in their
in their conditions
so it's not like um the class struggle
has disappeared i think this is also
maybe
a bit of a eurocentric um point of view
that
that leads to this conclusion
and yes so regarding extractivism
and how can we understand exploitation
or how can marx criticize um
the productive forces if there is
extractivism maybe
natural degradation but at the same time
wages are relatively
high i don't think well i think that in
order to understand this point we need
to look at marx's theory of wage
of the wage that has actually different
dimensions so
marks differentiate the nominal wage the
real wage and the relative wage yeah
so you can even have very high wages
relatively for example let's say harry
ford
when he inaugurated the assembly line
he said well he had the problem because
workers didn't want to work there
anymore because labor conditions were so
awful
right and so he said well the only way
to keep workers here
is to raise the wage to the five dollars
a day
and he says well this has basically
being the best
measure to cut labor costs that i have
ever taken right so by increasing wages
he has cut
labor costs reduced labor costs why
because of increased productivity
so in relative terms the relative wage
of the workers still they could earn
five dollars a week a day they could
buy their ford car maybe after i don't
know
one or two years but in relative terms
in comparison to ford's profits
they had actually become poorer right
and i think that this can apply to
different contexts like the one
the examples you made but also if we
look at for example
a chinese workers today because of their
struggles they have achieved many of
them industrial workers have achieved
improvements in their
real wages but still inequality is
skyrocketing in
in china because because uh why because
of
this difference between the relative
wage and the
real wage which is basically workers
purchasing power
um if i could respond to um one of your
points so i i mean i i take the point
about
uh sort of pastone kind of fetishizing
or perhaps referred addressing
um capital in capital in his
interpretation of capital but i
i i don't know there's something that
seems to me a little bit too optimistic
about your account because um
let's i mean let's take the environment
and and global warming and
climate change which i appreciate how
central it sort of it was in your
presentation
um i think that it's not
enough to think that the deleterious
effects
of climate change can be
sort of overrun by efforts of working
class alone right
the reality is that there are large
corporations that
are responsible for the vast majority of
carbon emissions
um in the sorry in the world today and i
think precisely what
postown is trying to point out that marx
is trying to point
out fine take away the part about
capital being the subject
of his critique what he's trying to
point out is that there's an increasing
disconnect between the working class as
the enabling sort of factor of
uh of capital production as you point
out
on the one hand and then uh you know
value on the other hand right like i i i
so
i i wonder if from the perspective of a
corporation
you know having to lose income for one
month every seven years just becomes a
new norm
it doesn't become a sort of disabling um
uh uh sort of factor i think that
precisely what deepest chakrabarty and
amitav ghosh
have pointed out with regard to climate
change is that it it forces us
to contend with problems for which the
will of the working class
alone is not enough maybe i'm being too
pessimistic though
yes but i don't i don't understand if
you expect uh
bazels or whoever to change their mind
and suddenly
you know say well we want a different
system i mean
that's not what i'm saying i'm i'm not
saying that it's just the working class
i think the working class is the center
of such a transformation
i think what what i'm trying to say even
with the examples of
anti-racism and the kind of different
uh kind of struggles is that it's
i i believe or the question about
production and reproduction
it's like it's just like having a focus
on production
doesn't exclude all the other spheres of
the total social reproduction of a
society
so the point is uh we need to unite
struggles around production and
reproduction
around racism imperialism
and so on and and the i think that
the real change social change can take
place
when they also expand to production
when there are i mean when there is a
kind of alliance or
a connection between um these struggles
that also involves the
the workers i mean this is this is what
happens
happened in the 70s um in
in many countries it was the the
connection between students workers
women and so on
that were able to actually achieve some
improvements
i i just believe we we forget this
and we have a very reductionist
interpretation of aleppo
struggles so
on the contrary the idea is like that
even
anti-imperialist resistance is a force
that is not external to the the class
struggle so it's
um it's a much broader and dynamic
conception of the class struggle from my
point of view that includes peasants
small peasants and and dispossessed
people and and so on so it's um i think
um
but i don't think that the corporation
will change their mind or attitude
so i wouldn't expect much from them
should we take a couple more
questions okay i'm going to forgive me
if i've missed your question somewhere
in the queue if i did
you can repost it towards the bottom and
i'll get to it
i'm going to read for felix buchwald
whose mic
is not working this question would you
agree that marx's own analysis
appears to show why a completely
globalized capitalist system is an
impossibility
his analysis of the centralization of
capital could be an example
as you noted this process necessarily
marginalizes particular world regions
what might this imply for your
interpretation of the passage from
chapter 24
on treating the world as one nation
perhaps there's a fourth possible
interpretation
you can you can read this yourself in
the in the chat
sorry can you this is felix buchwald
it's a little bit
i don't know 10 entries up from the
bottom image oh no that's just to me
i'll repost it to the whole group
thank you
and then while we're mulling that one
over can we go
to baruch jimenez contreras
who has a question can we unmute baruch
did you find him baruch he managed
us is there mike working
i don't know baruch are you are you here
you listen to me do you listen to me yes
yes
yes uh i i want to
to ask you what do you think about the
change in the viewpoint of the marxist
research in the united states which
previously
focused on the study of economic trends
like the the investigation of paranormal
and swissy
and now has a more humanistic and open
perspective like
thank you for that
great for the moment that's all our
questions
okay thank you
um can i ask um the person who posted
this question about the centralization
of capital maybe
uh to explain what they mean that
the centralization of capital is an
example of why
a completely globalized system is
impossible
that's for felix bouquet
maybe give some more explanation where
you
see this in marx's analysis that a
completely globalized system is an
impossibility and maybe while he does
that do you want to go on to baruch's
question
it could be
lucia okay
well that's an interesting question i
had never really
thought about the develop this
development of marx's scholarship in in
the united states
but i well i i know
the the work by sweden and so on and i
actually think that um
balami foster has quite a kind of um
it's an interesting global approach in
in the sense that is
uh analyzing different aspects of marx's
analysis from
the reserve army to the metabolic rift
and now for example coveted 19
so i i hadn't thought about it in
in these terms but it's uh surely
something
interesting to think about okay i don't
see
felix expanding on
his question or completely globalized as
opposed to a tendentially globalizing
attending tending to globalize i see the
distinction he's making
is between your reading of marx as
capturing this tendency and then the
idea of a completely globalized system
yeah so on the one side i agree
in the sense that um for example
sin even the idea of of the
centralization of capital max
talks about this process of
centralization
that tends towards basically the
concentration of property
of the property of capital in the hands
of
a single capital within a given society
yeah so he he talks in this in these
terms when he talks about the process of
centralization
so he sees this tendency towards
centralization
but at the same time of course this is
always a competitive process because
capital only exists in competition with
other capitals so
i don't uh put forward here the idea of
for example of
ultra imperialism yeah that would lead
to
a single process of centralization so
what i'm
arguing here is that because there is
always the link to the national economy
and the state
this tendency towards centralization
at the global level actually enhances
the competitive pressure between
different uh
capital is linked to specific uh
nation states yeah and so i see these
as an expression of the kind the kind of
tensions uh and tendency towards
inter-imperialist conflicts
uh expressed exactly by this on the one
side the tendency towards
us in the kind of the global level and
on the other side the continuing
presence of
competition which is inherent in the
process of
accumulation but um
[Music]
with regard to the idea that the process
might necessarily marginalize this
particular
word regions that's what i'm not
completely sure about
or i agree with because um
i don't understand what you mean by
marginalization
because uh i i understand this
marginalization as
an expression of the integration of
these regions in the capitalist
world markets not as an expression of
their exclusion from it
yeah so for example under development is
the result
of the development it's it's a part and
parcel of capitalist development on
a global scale rather than a result of a
lack of development
so these are why i wanted to hear from
you
but for sure there is a fourth possible
interpretation
and uh well uh maybe we could
uh we will discuss it in in future
can i ask you on that line just for your
bigger picture
do you think that the struggle is a
contingent
thing it sounds like it's quite
fragmentary it happens here it happens
there
or do you think like some interpretation
some marxist views
development is happening and when it
gets to a certain point
there'll be a general obstruction a
general disruption
it's like asking you to predict the u.s
election but
i'm curious how you see it moving not
whether you think it's going to happen
one way or the other
how does is it a systemic issue is it a
matter of necessity
as the fetishists of capital think it
will be
uh is it but if it's purely contingent
it's hard to imagine that struggles in
many different places
even if they happen all at once would be
anything other than absorbed
one way or the other back into
capitalist strategies
well i think it's difficult to answer
this question without
bringing in the question of organization
yes in the sense that i think
what we have witnessed for example over
the last 20 years is
for example big defeats yeah of the
united states
and europe in afghanistan in iraq
so this i mean there has been local
resistance that has
led to basically
quite substantial defeats uh but at the
same time
uh and these in my from my point of view
or for example
the new waves of such a struggles in
latin america
with the pink diet and so on this has
also
weakened the imperialist system from
cycling some points of view
so it has these factors have enhanced
the factors of crisis in the centers of
the system
and you have brzezinski and others that
say that quite clearly so we have this
awakening of the people in the global
south
and this is something we need to deal
with because it's a problem for us
right so we so we had these struggles
that
have weakened uh the system and in my
view have exacerbated the factors that
led to the global economic crisis in
2008
but at the same time what's missing here
is an international
and so i think that even for these to
then lead
to a kind of broader revolutionary
transformation globally
so we need though as as lanin said once
it's the subjective side that it's
always the biggest problem
thanks that's great well sign me up for
the international
and i bet you did a lot of people in the
audience there too
maybe since there aren't um
further questions there's another
question that i think is pretty marginal
about genetics and pathology i don't
really think that's relevant you can
answer it if you want to
otherwise we can thank you
here's here's another question do you
want to take that one do you see it
as the industrialization takes place
both in the developed and developing
world
does that affect the disruptive
potential workers have
have thanks to cooperation
does the increasing absorption of
workers by personal
services sector undermined disruptive
force
well i think as as i try to to discuss
the dynamics of workers power is complex
yeah so
for example the industrialization and
the shift of production can
weaken workers in a specific area
like the industrialized area while at
the same time
can create new uh scientists of
production and disruption
like for example the shift of production
to east asia
at the same time uh also the fact that
this is based on logistics and
connections and so on
can also create sources of power like
for example
uh of logistics logistics struggle
and so for example beverly silva
differentiates the
weakening of organized labor at the
labor market level
or even at the association in terms of
associational power
that we have witnessed in in europe and
in the united states over the last
40 years but at the same time you can
have
even um
certain uh
you can have new sources of power like
the example of the
logistics or or so on so this is
this is a this is a process that it's a
contradictory process i
i wouldn't just give a single answer so
it's
that for example the answer the audience
gave about
uh coverage 19 was was quite good so i i
do think that
it it creates both uh it both weakens
and creates new sources of power
and in terms of personal services sector
um well i think
this is a personal services what what do
you
mean exactly
maybe the service sector in general
which at least from the u.s perspective
has become a very huge
it's taken over where industry used to
be
are catering cab work food services
well for example uh in terms of um
food services or or even
um catering and so on i don't
i don't think it necessarily
reduces the power of disruption what per
se
because for example services that cannot
be
outsourced um so in services that cannot
be outsourced
workers can still have quite a lot of
disruptive
power i think key to
kind of long-term successes is probably
to link these struggles
also to struggles in production
so
people sense that you're about to leave
and that's making them anxious and ask
really good questions so if you don't
mind taking a couple more
yes okay so let's read out maybe i'll
just read them out
just
how do you think angles and marks
differed on their analysis of gender
issues
and then i'll point out vanessa
gubbins's question
um do you have thoughts about the limits
to accumulation how do you think about
that limit
what potential might it have and there's
finally a
question about automation whether
automation will undermine workers
leverage
globally
that's from michael pulsford
okay um
how do you think angus and max different
differed
on their analysis of gender issues
i need to think about this
social reproduction
it's very broad uh so
what do you think about it um
well the first thing i would say
i mean about this point is that
if we compare the max's notebooks
on gender and the family
and angus's origin of the
private properties the family and the
state
sorry guys it's 11 o'clock here so
uh so if we compare the two
the first thing i would say is that
angus had more of a kind of
evolutionist uh outlook
well uh max was also more interested
in the kind of persistence of different
forms of gender relations
and social relations around the world uh
for example in pre-capitalist societies
in the early 1880s
so one thing i would uh highlight um
about this difference which is which
isn't something i have really
investigated so far is that um
i think especially in the late years of
his life
marx was looking much more the kind of
differences
forms of social and gender relations
existing
globally and looking also their
potential
in terms of social transformation right
so the idea that social transformation
doesn't originate only
within capitalism but also forms of
opposition
over to to capitalism and and so
probably this um last evolution of
evolutionistic uh approach is something
i would
highlight about about marx but i'm
i'm not really i haven't studied this in
great that well
maybe we should suspend now given how
late it is there and
zoom gives you the the idea that you can
exploit people
without stopping so maybe we should give
you a chance to rest
what i can ask people to do whose
questions haven't been answered yet
is send them to me you can find me in
the german department at yale
and i can forward them to professor
pradella if that's okay with you
yes that's right okay why don't we do
that
and we thank professor pradella for a
really thought-inspiring presentation
this would be the huge applause
thunderous applause
okay